so the last remaining piece to fall from
the Trump crimes cover-up industrial
complex as I'm calling it is Deputy
Attorney General rod Rosen Stein who
submitted his resignation yesterday and
it will be effective in the first 10 or
11 days of May I believe and Rosenstein
was sort of a question mark for a while
in the sense that early on Rosenstein
could have been misinterpreted as maybe
a force for good we couldn't completely
tell maybe he was going to get in there
and make sure that things happen the way
they were supposed to happen in the
Muller probe maybe Rosen Stein would
resist letting Trump use the Justice
Department like his own sort of piece of
syllabus illy putty for his personal
benefit but in the end Rosen Stein ended
up being a lap dog and as the Washington
Post reported last year he told Donald
Trump on the phone that he is on Trump's
team more recently he stood up there
behind William bar during William bars
propaganda press conference looking sort
of like a golden retriever who just
wants to please their owner and is
worried he did the wrong thing and stood
by as one of the most blatant and
obvious miscarriages of justice was
completed by Donald Trump and by William
Bar and by the whole lot of them and
there's a lot to say about this
resignation because it really represents
so many things the letter itself if you
look at Rosen Stein's resignation letter
is a disgusting document and we don't
know yet whether this was force-fed to
him or he wrote it all by himself
like a big boy but it's vile and I'm not
gonna read it all to you but Rosenstein
praises Trump in the letter for the
courtesy and humor that Donald Trump
exhibited during his phone calls with
the deputy AG which is weird number one
because normally the president wouldn't
be having phone calls with the deputy AG
when that deputy AG is overseeing an
investigation into the president it's
weird number two because we've never
seen any evidence that Donald Trump
actually has what we would call a sense
of humor and then he just praised Trump
he praised Trump's accomplishments on
opioid abuse he praised Trump's
accomplishments on consumer protection
on immigration enforcement
it was a letter that sort of pretended
that things are just normal and that
this is a normal administration and
obviously the accomplishments that
Rosenstein claims Trump has to his name
are bogus but more importantly the real
accomplishment for Rosenstein is that he
participated in and oversaw one of the
most blatant public subjugation of the
processes of justice in the United
States for the partisan purposes of
protecting Donald Trump period that's
the real accomplishment which Rosenstein
ultimately has on his resume and which
will likely let him make a lot of money
once he's gone from the Justice
Department and much like William Barr
Rosenstein is a guy who knows how to
manipulate circumstances to get a
president out of trouble the opioids the
other stuff I mean give me a break
nobody's buying that unless you are
already completely in the tank on this
sort of no obstruction no collusion
witch-hunt side of things Jonathan Chait
wrote a really interesting article this
morning in New York Magazine and he says
he points out that the the most
concerning thing here is that in normal
situations presidents don't have
personal conversations with the Deputy
Attorney General at all and in
particular as I mentioned when the
Deputy Attorney General is supervising
an investigation into the president why
are they having casual conversation
where trumps being funny that's are an
extraordinary red flag and we have to
wonder I mean think about future
generations what will future generations
learn from this fiasco involving the
White House and the Justice Department
and these sort of marginal characters
that are on the periphery of this thing
they'll learn that in the United States
government if you're really corrupt you
can both get power and avoid the
consequences of your corruption which is
not really a lesson that many of us had
to be taught but it's really front and
center in this administration and
there's actually a bigger sort of
academic research area here why did all
of these career politicians bow down to
who in the end is a reality TV host
connected to organized crime and money
laundering and why did they put
everything on the line for Trump is it
that they're calculating there will be
untold financial rewards to be reaped in
the future I mean Rosenstein certainly
can now go and make a ton of money
lobbying or consulting or who knows what
but is there more to it like why even
when we go back to Michael Flynn and
Paul Manafort and all of these other
shady characters why were they so
willing to put themselves in harm's way
for Donald Trump when Donald Trump has
proven that his loyalty goes only as far
as he happens to think you're a cool
person that morning and otherwise that's
it it's over they can't actually be dumb
enough to think Trump is genuinely good
for the country can they or maybe being
naive curious what people in the
audience think about that today's
episode is sponsored in part by the BRD
Bitcoin wallet whether you have
experience with Bitcoin and crypto
currencies or you've been wanting to
give it a try for the first time BRD
offers the most elegant easy to use
Bitcoin wallet out there it's an app on
Android and iOS lets you trade crypto
currencies store all of your Bitcoin and
crypto on the app totally free send and
receive Bitcoin with the app use a
credit card to purchase cryptocurrency
and it's 100% private and secure
virtually impossible for someone to hack
your account BRD themselves won't even
know your information there are no
logins no passwords you just use your
key to access your Bitcoin and you're
the only one who has access to it it was
the first-ever Bitcoin wallet in the iOS
App Store they've been around since 2014
they have more than two million users
BRD is one of the oldest most
established and most trusted Bitcoin
wallets in the industry we recently
interviewed Aaron from the BRD team and
it was a great conversation you should
search our channel for it and check it
out all BRD wants to do is to make
Bitcoin more accessible and simpler to
you
for those who want to use it and that's
what they've accomplished with their
super powerful easy-to-use app download
it it's perfect for anyone who's just
getting started with Bitcoin just as
good if you already know what you're
doing I've put a link underneath this
video